[Musique]
portage la prairie au manitoba
depuis 20 ans ici chaque mois d'où on
célèbre la pomme de terre
petits et grands viennent d'y déguster
le populaire tubercule qui est devenu au
fil des ans le moteur économique de la
communauté
la pomme de terre cultivée dans sept
régions du manitoba depuis plus de 100
ans le sol sablonneux de ses champs se
prête bien à cette culture
si bien que depuis 2010 neuf le nombre
d'hectares consacrés à la culture de la
pomme de terre monte en flèche
et certains voient grand
je suis convaincu que le mento band
viendra les leaders de la production et
de la transformation de la pomme de
terre au pays brillent au plus haut
[Musique]
beaucoup
charles de nourrir l un des plus grands
producteurs de pommes de terre au
manitoba
mon grand-père s'est installé ici avec
sa famille ils se sont lancés dans la
culture de pommes de terre en 1966 et
des quelques 50 ha du début ils sont
passés à 500 ha en 2015
ils achètent de son père la ferme
familiale chaque année il est cultivera
toujours un peu plus d'hectares mais en
2019 il entreprend une expansion majeure
200 hectares d'un coup s'ajoute à la
ferme
un ajout qui lui coûtera cher c'est que
pour cultiver la pomme de terre dans
l'ouest il faut tirer gay et l'eau
nécessaire provient d'un puits qui se
trouve à trois kilomètres d'ici un
système comme celui ci avec un pivot
d'irrigation puis et un pipeline 5
octobre au bout deux cent cinquante
mille dollars multiplié sa part 3 et on
approche du million de dollars
[Musique]
il faut ensuite entreposés toutes ces
pommes de terre un seul hectare produit
jusqu'à cinquante six mille kilos de ce
légume
ces vieux entrepôts étant trop petite
chance de louise fait construire un
nouveau bâtiment hautement spécialisés
presque aussi grand qu'un terrain de
football
ici 80 millions de pommes de terre
peuvent être entreposés pendant des mois
dans un environnement où tout est réglé
au quart de tour
coût du projet 5 millions de dollars le
contexte actuel est très favorable aux
producteurs de pommes de terre qui
veulent prendre de l'expansion
les investissements importants se
multiplient on le voit
[Musique]
ans
ce qui le rassure autant c'est un autre
chantier à 25 kilomètres à l'est de sa
ferme
[Musique]
à portage la prairie l' usine de
transformation du géant américain tim
droite fait peau neuve
depuis 2003 la multinationale transforme
ici
près d'un million de kilos de pommes de
terre par jour en produits surgelés en
2017 simpson décide d'agrandir cette
usine au coût de 460 millions de dollars
aux comptes a piloté le projet
la demande pour les produits de pommes
de terre surgelées augmente sans cesse
il ya une montée de la classe moyenne
dans les pays émergents plus exposés à
la culture occidentale et au régime
alimentaire occidental tout cet attrait
pour les frais
[Musique]
l'expansion permettra à sim soit de
doubler ici sa production d'aliments
surgelés des produits surtout destiné à
la restauration rapide
nous avons conclu des ententes avec une
quarantaine de producteurs cherchent de
nouveaux ide
elle est aussi fournisseur l'expansion
en cours chez sam pelote le laisse
croire qu'ils sont ici pour longtemps
en tout cas c'est inspire confiance
depuis le 19e siècle l'île du prince
édouard a toujours été la reine de la
production de la pomme de terre au pays
[Musique]
elle y est cultivé sur plus de trente
quatre mille hectares soit 6 % de la
surface de la petite province à la terre
rouge et très sablonneuse c'était
pendant des décennies presque deux fois
plus que la surface semée en pommes de
terre dans les autres provinces
productrices
[Musique]
or le nombre d'hectares consacrés à la
pomme de terre à l'île du prince édouard
a plafonné les possibilités d'expansion
est temps limité
[Musique]
kevin mexique et le directeur général
des producteurs unique de pommes de
terre du canada comparé à l'ouest l'est
canadien du son industrie stanier
notamment raison de la réglementation
sur l'application des pesticides
aujourd'hui on a aussi tendance à penser
que la pomme de terre pousse mieux dans
un sol plus irrigué ce qui est
difficilement réalisable à
l'île-du-prince-édouard puisque le
forage de puits y est interdite et
l'île-du-prince-édouard et au petit
territoire
donc le potentiel d'expansion des terres
plantées en pomme de terre est assez
réduit
depuis dix ans les transformateurs
investit surtout dans l'ouest du pays
outre l'expansion majeur à l' usine de
steam droite
la société cavendish a ouvert en 2019
une nouvelle usine de transformation en
alberta
les nouveaux marchés de ces entreprises
étant surtout en asie les provinces de
l'ouest offre donc un réel avantage et
il y a aussi une question de rendement
les semences se font plutôt dans l'ouest
ce qui permet aux plantes de se
développer plus rapidement la période de
croissance est plus longue et les plans
tire profit des longues journées
ensoleillées du mois de juin ajoutez à
ça qu'on système d'irrigation et le
potentiel de rendement dans l'ouest
devient excellent alors que le rendement
moyen à l'île du prince édouard est de
33 mille kilos de pommes de terre par
hectare
la production au manitoba est nettement
plus élevée près de 38 mille kilos par
hectare en alberta le rendement est plus
élevé encore 43 mille kilos par hectare
à l'été 2010 9 ch de nous il s'attend à
une excellent rendement
la récolte va bon train et on voit déjà
des pommes de terre d'une belle grosse
heure donc on est très optimiste pour la
suite des choses
mais les producteurs de l'ouest ont tout
de même des défis importants
la météo imprévisible à l'automne et un
gel souvent hâtif à l'île du prince
édouard on peut récolter les pommes de
terre jusqu'au début novembre
mais dans l'ouest après l'action de
grâce c'est pour ainsi dire terminée la
fin de saison souvent à bruch représente
un défi en septembre 2019 des orages
violents s'abattent sur le sud du
manitoba les champs se transforme en
grandes étendues de boue lorsque celle
de louis brigitte enfin à entamer la
récolte en octobre
le travail est ardu
la machinerie s'embourbe
l'équipement encaissent un dur coup les
déplacements sont encore difficiles ça
complique beaucoup la récolte il réussit
tout de même à tirer se récolte du sol
la qualité est excellente c'est la pomme
de terre idéale la longueur correspond
parfaitement à ce que cherchent les
transformateurs donc on sait que la
qualité
c'est la première fois que cheikh de
nous y cultive des pommes de terre sur
une si grande superficie
c'est en quelque sorte son baptême de
feu
on a ajouté de la machinerie pour
récolter de manière plus efficace
on a beaucoup d'hectares à couvrir ici
on plante des pommes de terre qu'on en
prend soin mais qu'au final on ne peut
pas tout les ramasser on a un vrai
problème
ses 45 employés travaillent jour et nuit
est riche c'est à sortir la quasi
totalité de la récolte juste à temps
la neige arrive quelques hectares
seulement sont perdus
la récolte remplir a presque
complètement son nouvel entrepôt
14 millions de kilos de pommes de terre
prêtes à être livrées aux
transformateurs
[Musique]
en février 2020 la nouvelle chaîne de
production à l'usn de sim droite reçoit
ses premières cargaisons de pommes de
terre
lusine transforme maintenant près de
deux millions de kilos de pommes de
terre par jour
[Musique]
sim porte veut acheter encore plus de
matières premières
[Musique]
oh
on prête en 2020 celle de no id augmente
d'un autre 200 hectares les superficies
qui sema pommes de terre on est à noter
que les turcs
si on a l'occasion de prendre de
l'expansion en 2020 vingt-quatre mille
hectares sont semées en pommes de terre
en alberta tandis qu'au manitoba
on atteint presque les trente mille
hectares c'est 5000 de moins qu'à l'île
du prince édouard mais avec des
rendements nettement plus élevés
les provinces des prairies sont sur le
point de faire ce qui aurait été
impensable il ya dix ans devenir le
berceau de la production de la pomme de
terre au pays
[Musique]
malgré les sommes faramineuses kutcher
d'une wii vient de dépenser dans sa
ferme
il est convaincu que le rendement de son
investissement vaudra son pesant d'or
[Musique]
la pomme de terre et où menu de peu près
tous les bases et plus la population
augmentera plus il y aura de gens à
nourrir alors je pense que notre
stabilité financière est assurée à long
terme
[Musique]